una persecución que duró toda la noche
el presunto autor del ataque armado
masivo fue finalmente detenido en la
mañana del viernes para la misión se
estableció un perímetro y puestos de
control muy estrictos en dubonna 60
kilómetros al sur de Belgrado policía y
ambulancias estaban en el lugar
helicóptero sobrevolaban el tirador que
abrió Fuego contra un grupo de personas
la noche del jueves desde un vehículo
huyó después
es terrible para nuestro estado
es una gran derrota por desgracia
en dos días han muerto tantos niños no
es bueno
esta nueva tragedia se produjo menos de
48 horas después del asesinato masivo de
nueve personas entre ellas 8 menores a
manos de un joven de 13 años en una
escuela un tiroteo que ha conmocionado
profundamente al país el presidente
Alexander buschich condenó la escalada
de violencia
este nuevo ataque criminal masivo
después de un ataque a nuestros hijos se
centró aleatoriamente en cualquier
persona que estuviera en la mira del
tirador Este es un ataque a todo nuestro
país y todos los ciudadanos lo lamentan
Serbia inicia este viernes un período de
luto de tres días y se espera que el
ministro del interior refuerce las
medidas de control de armas en el país
también serán desplegados al menos 1200
policías en las escuelas